[Music]
meet bella esmeralda
cristiano ronaldo and his girlfriend
georgina rodriguez announced the name of
their newborn daughter on saturday
georgina took to instagram with a
slideshow of her baby girl in her crib
the model captioned it quote bella
esmeralda
1804-22 to mark the baby's birthday of
april 18 2022
news of the baby's name comes after the
couple revealed on social media that the
little girl's twin brother died during
childbirth
writing quote it is with our deepest
sadness we have to announce that our
baby boy has passed away it is the
greatest pain that any parents can feel
days after announcing the tragic news
the pro soccer player shared this family
photo with his newborn daughter on
instagram captioning it quote home sweet
home before thanking fans for their
quote kind words and gestures
writing quote your support is very
important and we all felt the love and
respect that you have for our family
he concluded his post by writing quote
now it's time to be grateful for the
life that we've just welcomed into this
world
the couple announced they were expecting
twins back in october sharing these
sonogram photos alongside a caption that
read in part quote our hearts are full
of love we can't wait to meet you
bonitos
cristiano and georgina give fans an
inside look at their lives on her
netflix series i am georgina
and her pregnancy was well documented on
social media including this special
moment from their gender reveal party
[Music]
yay
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
cristiano and georgina have been
together since 2017 and are also parents
to alana eva and matteo and cristiano is
dad to 11 year old cristiano jr and
while the couple mourns the loss of
their son on social media they shared
this message to him
quote you are our angel we will always
love you